Oh!... thumbnail
Hi guys, my name is Grace Helbig. If you did not know, now you know. Your life is different now!
I'm here with Todrick Hall!
Which you guys should know, because if you know me you know I'm obsessed with this human being, because he's just a bundle of talent that just oozes constantly
Not a good enough reason to say oozes
I feel very raw because we just shot a video for Todrick's channel in which we revealed some of our deepest darkest secrets
Stuff that I don't think either one of us have told other humans in years
or ever
So after this is done, please go over to his channel and check out that video because we're very sweaty.
but now we're having happy fun times here!
Todrick is a broadway veteran. You've been in 3 Brodaway shows now?
Yeah
And the most recent one was Kinky Boots, which I got to see in New York, and you were so outstanding.
I cried my eyes out. so fantastic. your makeup and your entire look was incredible.
thank you. And I know that you are such a huge fan of RuPaul's Drag Race.
So these two things combined I thought Todrick might be the perfect version to do drag makeup on my face
Except for fun fact: I've never done makeup in my entire life, but I think that I could be good at it
I'm no Manny MUA
Or Jeffrie Star
Or Patrick Star but I'm Todrick star for today
No, I texted you this and you were like I've never done makeup before. I was like "perfect."
I assume that you dabble?
She's not dabble
So let the dabbleation begin.
This is your canvas, you can do whatever you want.
I want you to look good
I don't want it to be look like a trash box.com
That is my brand
These colors are all so light, first of all. I don't know what to do with them
Not only drag, but it's drag on a drug store budget, which is like
Already setting us up for failure a little bit
How long it take you to do Lola's makeup? Like to do Lola make up?
about an hour, every day. An hour and a half
are you serious?
For my look for my Low video..
That's insane. That's amazing
but that look took like three or four hours.
What is this? That is foundation.
So okay?
Do I just like put this on your face? Sure. This not coming out...
Seems very sexual
Okay. Oh my god. I don't know where to even start okay? I know that there's like a lot of contouring that happens
Yes.
And I see people do this all the time, and literally look the same as when we started?
What is...Which one sould I do contoring with?
Whatever one you want. You're an artist.
Do that.... A little more of that... this looks kind of good...
yeah? COME ON ME!
Wait are you contoring my nose?
Don't open your eyes... like you're for sure in a bad production of Cats or something
Cats was hysterical. Kinky Boots made me feel things.
How tall are the boots?
The boots are six... five and a half inches
that... I can't even walk in five and a half inch heels
I'm literally a gazelle that walks on ice. Like that's how I walk normally. It's just fall down city.
on this. You're never going to want to take this off.
You've bever looked more beautiful. Thank God it's Friday night! TURN IT OUT. TGIF. GO GET LIT!
Something like... I can't take you seriously right now.
I'm very intently listening.
You're definitely using black liquid liner on the eye brows.
This eyebrow is a mess.
Or is it great?
If you need to book me like get me soon, because after this video, I'm gonna be like in high demand.
*Todrick humming*
Take me seriously!
Okay, you gotta be still because I have Kim Kardashian after this. Like really serious makeup.
You look like an F*ing wreck. Thank you! You're welcome.
Are you a good make up artist? NO! how do people do this? my hand is like literally
I feel like you're so scared about poking me, but don't worry beauty is pain.
I've just never poked a girl before.
Is it?
You have a lot of good real estate up here.
thank you... oh just the bags under my eyes you mean?
Yeah, I'm very tired.
I think you'd be great at that putting like a boy band together.
I just miss Dream
Remember when P.Diddy put Dream together?
Didn't P. Diddy put together danity cane. That's what I remember.
yeah he also put together dream
Who was in Dream?!
GIrl, I don't know.
Did I make.. did I dream?
You dreampt that s*.
this is... I know I closed my eyes, but you can put that glitter wherever you want. Okay
Grace they not gonna be able to handle you when you hit the scene.
no no no.
Now you need a little blush.
You're ready for Broadway Grace. Can you sing?
No I can scream. What's your karaoke song?
Well when I'm trying to impress someone like if there's a cute guy then I will sing "I'll Be" by Edward McKaine and look them straight in the eye
sings: "I'll be your crying shoulder"
But if it's just like a Tuesday, I'll sing "I Love Rock and Roll"
This is the most awkward thing, when people are like:
I ate some of it
I like those. I think if we're gonna go big, we should.
Go big or go home. Yeah.
Look at you.
I've seen people do this. This is what the kids are doing.They are giving their eyelashes blowjobs. So I'm gonna do it to.
Yes!
Do I look wide awake?
sings: wide awake
Now, I just want to give you a little bit of personality you know?
Okay!
Cause everyone can put make up on, but not everybody can be Grace Helbig.
oh boy!
and I wanna give my signature thing
Marilyn... Mmm thank you! You're welcome.
Did you do it?
I think you're ready.
Are we there?
I think you're ready to hit the stage.
Oh my God
wow!
YES!
You honestly did not do a bad job!
THANK YOU!
And these eyebrows.
Thick and strong, these eyebrows have a lot of personality especially this one up here.
Yeah it does
She's alert.
My nose has never looked skinnier. Thank you.
Oh my God this was so fun. Guys give me some recommendations for drag queen names down in the comments below, because I feel ready.
You're ready
to live my best life.
Yes!
Thank you so much Todrick.
You're Welcome.
And like we already said go over to Todrick's channel because we revealed some really
deep...dark
sexual secrets over there
And make sure you guys check out a future episode of Not Too Deep cause Todrick is going to be a guest on it and it's going to be so fun.
Go follow Todrick everywhere. And we'll see you guys whenever I don't know
See them at the gay club tonight. Right now. Goodbye.